some things we just appreciate we
appreciate our sports stars for example
I mean we appreciate their greatness we
Fisher what we see as it's an
appreciation and also there is um you
know an identification identity that we
have also with movie stars that say or
you know we have this so I think justice
intrinsic appreciation for for science
as something that we normally do and
that's something we are we are anyway I
mean there's a great sin by abdeslam
Nobel laureate who said the I think the
common heritage of mankind is some
scientific thought something along those
lines scientific inquiry rather so I
think that um you know in the first
first influence for me I think a big
part that literacy that I think is my
opinion is that is lacking is just a
basic appreciation at the level of this
is part of our culture because it is and
also you know we we talk about breaking
down the barriers of how scientists
versus who's cool and who's not cool or
stereotype I think that the minute those
barriers or I would say the men we take
up and we take advantage of the
opportunity that a scientists can also
be a rock star or a rock star hit also
be really interested in science and
that's okay you know the same way Herbie
Hancock you know a great musician for
example might like to play around his
electronics I'm Brian Eno a friend of
mine would like to you know extent ideas
of modern physics into his musical
creation that might try to be a
number-one hit or the same way Kanye
West might you know use very advanced
electronic devices to make top-notch
Beats or Timberland you know once these
things are just you know be it's become
more commonplace I think science will we
will just naturally become more litter
in science because its intrinsic to us I
don't know much about sort of the allow
the political players specifically I
mean I do have for example there's one
person I do have known for a long time
of knowing his work especially in New
York City he's representative and in
northern Manhattan his name is Mark
Levine he was like a physics major in
college and he could have completely
gone on and become a great physicist but
he decided to you know again to public
service and and you know you were
running for City Council soon and and he
is someone that for example sees the
value of a literate a more literate
public appreciative public of science
but and also that you can easily study
science but you can do other things and
it would be very useful to what you do
and it's never too late to become a
scientist for example that's what I
really
from what I've seen you know for example
visiting primary schools high schools
and think k12 over the years is that I
think the we need to continue to relate
the the world after school that these
kids experience to what to science that
they they learn in school so and we also
need to show these kids that like role
models scientists that look like them
that act like them maybe or you know you
could be a brilliant potential scientist
as a young person but you may not
necessarily have the personality traits
that stereotype that that a scientist
should have that all you see on on the
movies and I think that these things are
slowly changing but more the more we
start breaking down the what a scientist
looks like acolyte think like the better
job will do at the level of primary
school module of course resources and we
need to continue putting the resources
in there one thing I should I did we
learn recently was that Barack Obama
when he was he did research for some law
professor when he was at Harvard where
he sort of was you know the student I
was leading the project for this
professor and they connected Einstein's
theory of general relativity to the
legal sphere and apparently that paper
is out and so I found out really
interested in that you know he had to go
and teach himself a little bit of
appreciate general relativity to help
this professor write this paper so I'm
hoping that you know candidates like
himself as they continue on an office at
the high level would actually start
investing into into science literacy
because it's very I mean it's so
important that we are not just if you
want to say recipients of science but
also in in in our own ways contribute to
our to science